this really jumps the shark when
they went to their virtue signaling
we're going to save the planet schtick
which is
you know in fairness to them they do
talk the talk and walk the walk
they are going to be carbon neutral they
do care about the environment they will
take their
your products back to recycle them
that's all uh fine and well
but when they went to this shot of the
roof
of the mothership headquarters and
i couldn't believe what they were
telling me here but listen to this folks
we've also been transitioning our iphone
manufacturing partners to renewable
energy
okay that's great renewable energy is
perfect we looked for ways to cut waste
and use less material
okay i'm with you cut waste is a great
idea over 700 million lightning
headphones
okay we got headphones many customers
have moved to a wireless experience
yep wireless headphones
definitely and there are also over two
billion apple power
i don't understand i bought all these
adapters from you i got them in every
room the billions of third-party
adapters yeah i buy the anchor points
you're better than yours
reduces carbon emissions and avoids the
mining
and use of precious materials what i
paid these items also means a smaller
lighter iphone box and this is where my
engines was like they're charging you
1200
for a phone but they took out the
charger because there's already two
billion on the platted
and they took out the headphones because
they want you to buy the 300
ones i mean and then they're explaining
to us that it's a smaller footprint
and the box is smaller because they took
stuff out
but this is in your best interest and
better for the planet okay
i get you apple uh i see what you did
there
you're basically took everything out
except for and this is where you know
everybody went crazy
uh on the twitter
not only to have the audacity to tell
you you don't need a charger with your
new 1200
phone and you don't need headphones with
your new 1200 phone it's not like they
lowered the price on this thing it's
still expensive
um but then the audacity is
they still use a lightning connection so
if they actually did care
about chargers and they do care they do
care about the environment
why not go with the standard usbc then
we don't need as many of these
you make us buy a usbc for our
ipad pros you make us buy it for our
macbooks
and our macbook airs and macbook pros
and every other
device is moved to usbc except for this
one device
which still makes us buy redundant
lightning cables
so forgive me but i find this ridiculous
let's watch the rest of this video shot
on the uh
solar panel roofed of the mothership we
can fit up to 70 percent
more products on a shipping panel right
reducing carbon emissions in our global
logistics chain that's why i'm buying an
iphone
i want to get the global logistics
changes we've made for iphone 12
cut over 2 million metric tons of carbon
emissions
annually great it's like removing 450
000 cars from the road fantastic
this is huge and we're really proud that
apple is taking the lead
we hope others will follow making this
impact even bigger for our planet
all right so i thought that was like
ridiculous and disingenuous they should
have said hey we took the 50
off the price of it because we're saving
so much money for you but
they didn't say that